this is the last subtopic under areas
under curves under areas under curves so
we did with integration we had a look at
these methods of approximation and then
volumes
now what's this about if you recall like
first one or two lessons we would target
integration right we said that the whole
idea of integration was raised as a
solution to area right so we've got this
kind of notation yeah
now area equals and then there are three
parts to this okay there's that
rido looking yes there's this DX on the
end and then you I don't like f of X or
Y or whatever in there now just help me
draw the memory right what do these
three parts what do they each signify
let's start from the right hand side
what is the DX where did that come from
it's the width of that little rectangle
that we imagined right so we are taking
area and area has that dimension and it
also has what's the Y course without
yeah that's the height and the tricky
thing about it is that the height
changes as you go to different parts of
the curve right so that's why I don't
just call it H which is constant I can't
why it's a function the heights changing
all the time right what was this be on
the front
yeah okay so I guess if you wanted to
put one word it's like where are we
interested in all of these Heights and
widths and put it all together okay
now let me taken this idea
I said look when you do this summation
right because it was from Sigma notation
right you take the sum of this thing
integration 1
you can take the sum of anything do you
remember what the example that I gave
you was which wasn't just a rectangle we
took the sum of something else a shape
you're familiar
remember yeah we thought about circles
in particular we thought about the
surface area on the sphere remember that
right and we looked at this result we
said well if we take the sub-series Fiat
which is 105 squared right and the width
of the each one is our DX okay and what
was that domain where we'll be go from
where we start finish what's that what's
the smallest surface area of a like
shell that I would take what would its
radius be zero right and then you go all
the way up to R we looked at that idea
okay I just want you to see the parallel
between these two still the same
summation still something of infinite
decimal no sorry infinite goodness you
feel it testing this small anyway right
but then what were you put in here was
drastically different that's not height
at all it's the area of a shell right so
the idea is that you can use integral to
add up anything you like so almost all
the things that you've got a really tiny
now I didn't take this idea that I can
take the integral I can integrate a
whole bunch of anything I like by
thinking about let's take a function and
I'm gonna start with a simple one one
that you could find its volume in other
ways and see how I could muck around
with it and then use integration so if I
had this function okay let's say I was
interested in the domain
okay so I could work out the area of
this well it's a rectangle back to
working out by integration what integral
I fought for this particular you to go
off one of my boundaries five in one and
I'm interested in this bounded with the
x-axis so that's going to give me an
area okay but here's what I want to do
I'm just like from here to here I went
from a height to let the shell I'm
interested in what happen if I took all
of these little rectangles that's what
this is right and each rectangle has
fight to so for instance one little
rectangle like that and what if I make
that rectangle the radius of a circle
now where would the circle go okay now
being that I've got a whole bunch of
these rectangles rather make a circle
fit that way the way we're looking at it
okay I want you to mention the circle
going further into the war and coming
out okay so it's kind of looks like this
okay so I've taken that I've made a
raisin now go to seven okay now what
happens if I get a whole bunch of those
you know what kind of shape am I going
to get I can if you're having trouble
visualizing this okay I'm gonna draw it
a favor from some math teachers of the
past and I want to reference them so so
mr. Collett and mrs. cannon you remember
mr. Hallett but mrs. cannon is before
your time she was almost before my time
but I remember when she was around so
they they put these together now what is
this well it's a silly okay but how was
it made is the important thing you can
see if you want to think about it that
way rather than shells spherical shells
I have of kind of like slices right and
then these are all the seconds that have
been made that I've put together
I can you put enough into here and you
get a solid shape into grants here it's
a solid okay now what I'm interested in
is is integrating putting together
combining all of these don't you get a
volume at the end so you can see why
it's called a solid above there's not so
named because they're on one history
fans but it's by taking that radius
right and this is important on your
diagram get another color on it the way
I make this cylinder is by taking that
radius and room
all vignettes around the x-axis alright
now how would I find we're already
expecting but this is going to be a
volume of some client okay you put
together a bunch of one-dimensional
things and you'll get a two dimensional
measurement you put it together a bunch
of two-dimensional things we ought to
get a three-dimensional thing which is
of all now my boundaries are still the
same I'm still going from one to five
but instead of a two what's going to be
here now instead of just like a lion
right what I've made is a circle okay
but we don't know what the area of a
symbol is right what's the area of a
circle now in this case my radius is
four okay so I'm gonna get pi times 2
squared yeah I'm sorry radius is 2 right
2 squared is 4 and I need a width
I need a width so what am I going to get
out of this well let me just note item
so this is 1 it's a 5 DX
okay now you tell me I know I could take
a lot of things out but I'm just going
to leave for now I'm gonna leave
what is the integral what's the
primitive function from full-time it's
just the constant right X from 1 to 5
let's go ahead and evaluate it right
what do I get I'm going to get 25 -
buh-bye
yes so that's 16 5 and of course because
I'm actually work out a volume you can
conclude this ought to be 16 PI units
cute okay now here is why I chose this
shape because we know how to work out
the volume of soda right what's our
regular formula it's uh it's PI R
squared H this is this is my base right
so it's a prism so what is it in this
case what's my radius is good and what's
my height it's 4 1 if I was 4 right so
it looks like it checks out at least in
this case so can i generalize this a
little bit this is one specific example
where was the crucial step that took us
from I'm working at areas to working out
volumes what was different the boundary
was the same the width of each Viton
width of each of these slices if you
like was the same what was different was
what am i cutting up on adding up these
shapes now I'm not adding up these
little rectangles of an ellipse circles
so therefore this is the crucial part
here
okay
because in adding up circles I really
hang on these PI R Squared's right a
whole bunch of areas
so let's generalize it suppose it wasn't
why it was - okay suppose it was you
know whatever function you're like okay
how would I find its area well the
volume is going to be you peak wherever
you want it to be served from A to B now
because I'm adding up a bunch of circles
right this is going to be PI R squared
but the radius will each time be Y
whatever the height is so instead of
applying a screenplay once and then of
course I've got the width of each of
those slices
now Richard notice before this pi is a
constant okay so it makes sense to bring
this up so this is our expression for
and you won't put like a nice big box
around this okay this is our expression
for a solid of revolution and follow you
that you get by taking a function and
rotating it around a Centon answers in
this case it's the x axis that's what
the DX signifies okay just like before
the DX signifies an area bounded by the
x-axis this is evolving you around the
essence